fighting climate change has become the
greatest responsibility of our times
and this is why in europe we have set
our objective
to become the first carbon neutral
continent by 2050.
this means leading an entire continent
towards
transitioning to clean energy
reinventing our infrastructure and much
much more it may sound abstract
and it sounds huge and yes it's actually
both
and it is also possible
why in the european union we have a good
record of
turning ambitions into successes we are
a political
and economic union with 27 countries and
a total population of 450 million people
on the ashes of two world wars we have
secured
lasting peace among us from a divided
continent
we have created a union without borders
and i strongly believe we can also
achieve our next challenge
becoming the first carbon neutral
continent
when i became president of the european
commission i send a clear signal
in the first two weeks i tabled the
european green deal
this european green deal is both our
vision for climate neutral continent
and a very dedicated roadmap to this
goal
it is 50 actions for 2050
ranging from the first ever european
climate law
to circular economy to a biodiversity
strategy
planting trees protecting precious
nature and animals
recycling and waste management just to
name a few
when the coronavirus pandemic hit we
resolved not to let our objective be
derailed
the economic and social crisis created
by the pandemic
cannot be an excuse to postpone the
transition
towards a cleaner and healthier future
on the opposite they create
an additional accelerator to mobilize
and to move
ahead of course
not everyone agreed some in the industry
told us it was impossible to remain
competitive under these new constraints
some unions were afraid jobs would be
lost
and workers forgotten some politicians
said
it was not realistic we listened to them
but we also listened to other facts and
arguments
the large international support to the
paris agreement
science with robust data and more data
every year
the evidence of climate shifting all
around us
we all know it by now glaciers melting
forest fires more extreme weather events
and this is just the beginning
we saw the prospect of many new jobs
created by the transition
european citizens who in their
overwhelming majority
consider that climate change is a very
serious problem
our youth demanding action for their
future
and rightly so building on this
in september 2020 we announced we would
go
one step further we moved from a 40
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions by
2030
to an at least 55 reduction by 2030.
we are taking this bold commitment for
two reasons
first we already know that we need to
push
further if we are serious about reaching
our 2050
objective which we are
and second the more we progress
the more we rally our 2030 and 2050
timelines
are ambitious they are also necessary
solving climate change will help
solve a host of other problems
ignoring it will only precipitate them
as we see with the link between the loss
of biodiversity and zoonotic viruses
like the coronavirus
i know some are concerned with this
transition
and i want to tell them these concerns
are legitimate
but we have the knowledge we have the
technology
we have now the resources to accompany
this change and make
this transition just
we are directing our recovery in this
direction
if we get it right a third of our
recovery money
called next generation eu and of our
long-term budget
will go to climate goals and climate
projects
and this is more than 600 billion euros
now addressing climate change will need
more than
politicians and more than a continent
states companies cities citizens
everywhere need to move in the same
direction and to sustain their action
over the long term
the european union is open to cooperate
with anyone who is ready to engage in
this journey
fixing climate change calls for
everyone's action
every day you can count on me
i count on you thank you